and this morning we are getting an
exclusive look with the US Coast Guard
at the damage in the Bahamas from above
CBS Evening News anchor Norah O'Donnell
took off from the Coast Guard Air
Station in opa-locka Florida yesterday
and she saw the devastation from a Coast
Guard plane but definitely this will be
something that we'll be working with for
a while
Coast Guard lieutenants Jillian Horner
and Juliana White flew us over the
battered islands of the Bahamas we
requested to fly along with them to see
what is this unfolding humanitarian
crisis standing in the back of an HC 144
cargo plane the destruction in Abaco was
clear Grand Bahama Island also took a
beating but we did land briefly in
Nassau it's incredibly busy here at this
Airport in Nassau you've got the Navy
you've got the US Coast Guard Robert and
Phyllis cornea are seeking refuge in
NASA
they say the category 5 storm destroyed
their home in Abaco the island they
lived on for more than 50 years all the
buildings all the main buildings had
gone restoration Abaco co-founders
Heather hunt and Sandra cook described
the desperation the looting has begun
and these people are armed
they're going after homes that are still
intact that I've cost up generators
maybe food you know it's bad for CBS
this morning I'm Norah O'Donnell in
opa-locka Florida